[Music]
all right let's roll out to Georgia and
talk to the great and wonderful Matt
what's up Matt hey John Dr John how are
you I'm partying man what about you I'm
living the dream I
guess man I I I want to wake up from my
dream sometimes what's up D yeah yeah
yeah exactly so um the question I have
is the current situation between my wife
and I um isn't great um I'm actually
about to move out into an apartment okay
um what what happened so to give you
some backstory I went through a period
of time where I drank too much on the
weekends basically Friday night Saturday
Sunday um what's a period of time I
would say probably a year and a half two
years just kind of out of the
blue um I would say it ramped up after
I've got two daughters five and three
and I would say it ramped up after my
second daughter was born okay
cool um so it was something my wife had
confronted me about um more than one
occa on more than one occasion and it
came to a head on Memorial Day um my
oldest daughter the 5-year-old came out
on the deck where I was to ask me a
question and actually ended up falling
through a weak part in the railing about
12 feet and landed on concrete below
that you fell you fell or she fell she
fell my daughter fell okay so um rushed
to the emergency room um they did X-rays
and all that found a small fracture in
her jaw a few days later we took her to
a specialist he said it was the best
case scenario she'd be good to go in
like three weeks to a month no surgeries
needed just don't let her eat hard candy
basically and stuff yeah um man I'm so
sorry after that I appreciate it man it
was rough and um after that my wife had
told me she's like listen I don't know
if I'm going to be able to bounce back
from this um what did you have to do
with what
happened well I would say her falling
could have happened with anybody being
out there um the problem was is that
with my drinking too much I was letting
things go around the house becoming
disconnected with my wife and my kids um
and even my job during the week when I
didn't drink was starting to or some so
um I put the blame on myself as far as
not fixing the railing um putting on the
back
burner um but something else hold on
something else happened that that was a
final straw for your wife were you not
paying attention out there were you
goofing off no I was but I I had had two
beers at that point and before we took
my daughter the emergency room I told my
wife I had not had any and of course all
she's got to do is look in the trash can
and see two beer cans
and um that was what triggered her um
her reaction more so than anything
else and um can I be honest with hold on
hold on can I be honest with you man
something's not adding up to me yes
sir if if if you and I are going to talk
you're gonna have to be a 100% open well
no and like I said I I just wasn't
honest with her about when and how much
I was drinking yeah but two beers is not
hey we're done well I think it was more
the fact that I like to her and told her
I hadn't been drinking than the amount
that I had been
drinking um and the the fact that it
happened on more than one
occasion that you'd had two
beers no no no I mean normally I would
drink more than that but I'm saying at
the point when this happened it wasn't
that I had been drinking necessarily it
was I lied about the fact that I had
been
drinking
okay I'm struggling with it but go ahead
continue so she said I can't come back
from this she said that at that time so
um I put forth a good bit of effort I
completely stopped
drinking um really worked on being
emotionally there for my kids and my
wife and not just physically there
started exercising again losing some
weight all the all the you know good
things that come along with Lifestyle
Changes um went on a family vacation had
a really good time skip ahead to Labor
Day um
I was kind of having an off weekend we
went out on a date Saturday I wasn't
really communicating with her um I was
supposed to get the girls ready for
church on Sunday I didn't have them
ready when it was time to leave I could
tell something was off with my
wife um that night she actually told me
that she was kind of trying to make
herself fall back in love with me but it
hadn't
happened um she just couldn't let go of
the things that had happened
and at that point she said she thought
it would be best if I found an apartment
so so be super clear with me man you
your daughter had an accident that you
had two two beers by any stretch of the
imagination you weren't close to
intoxicated she fell out and got hurt
yes from that moment your wife said I
don't think we're going to be able to
come back from this now you didn't tell
your wife the truth about two beers what
were you doing those other times you
were drunk because
you here here's the deal you're you're
speaking very evasively and you're
speaking very distant from you know I
would I had a beer and then like you
know like maybe I wasn't your wife is
preferring to be a single mom with two
kids than be with you well the problem
was is that say for example we get the
kids ready for bed put them in their
bath get them ready for bed and
everything I had already been drinking
so she felt like it wasn't safe to have
the kids around me
and I didn't do anything violent I
wasn't abusive I didn't black out or
pass out or anything I just basically
drank more than I should
have
so you didn't hit anybody you didn't
cheat on your wife you didn't swear at
anybody
no your wife just said I'm
out well things got better for a while
until like I said the lab weekend which
is when she made that decision about I
think it'd be better if you got an
apartment and what was her reasoning
behind that because she in the past she
didn't trust me anymore um she didn't
feel secure with me um she wasn't in
love with me
anymore
um and to be honest two weeks after that
when I had an apartment and I was
getting ready to move out we listened to
a snippet from one of your shows that
was kind of in the same vein as what I'm
going through right now and after we
listened to it she said I don't want you
to move out but if you want this to work
I need these things to
happen and basically it was me being
more involved in the finances me
continuing to um improve my relationship
with her and the
girls um but unfortunately after a
couple more weeks things hadn't really
got any better and the decision was made
again for me to just find an apartment
and that's where we're at right now okay
have yall G to get sit down with a
professional yes we're going to coup's
counseling and I'm also going
individually have youall already started
that or are you're going to go we
already started the couples last week
was my first week that I met with my
therapist okay and is
anything coming up in couples's
counseling that is is an aha moment for
the both of
you no um I mean she said some things
that were kind of an aha to
me but nothing that myself or the
therapist is saying have really
triggered anything for
her she says that nothing's changed as
far as her feelings and she basically
said there's nothing I can do which of
course there are things I could do to
make the situation
worse but as far as helping her get past
what she's holding on to there's nothing
I can
do
so there's a missing piece here um and
I've just had this conversation too too
often one of two things is true either
your wife has been looking for an exit
strategy for a season
now and or slowly got so far away from
you that she feels that she can't come
back that's number one or number two you
are using language and anybody who's
hung out with people who struggle with
alcohol addiction would recognize your
language the way you're you're talking
to me that you aren't fully being
upfront with everything and I don't know
what that means I don't know what that
what that is but there's
either she's got some really significant
challenges
or um you're not you're not being for
that if I were to talk to her I'd get a
radically a very different picture of
you than what I'm getting right now I
would say if you talk to her she would
probably I would say it's the the first
scenario
the distance was created by my
dishonesty
basically because you lied one time
about having two beers no I lied that's
what I'm saying is I was dishonest
multiple times about how much I had
drank that one particular instance was
kind of the straw that broke the camel's
back okay well here's my rule for moving
out to try to get some space to see if
we're going to save this thing MH is
number one there has to be a specific
time frame
okay and I usually don't wouldn't I
would never recommend unless there's
physical abuse that it's over 30
days so I'm out for 30 days and we have
some agreed touch points we will talk I
will pick the girls up we will we have
to negotiate these rules out ahead of
time otherwise it's going to build
resentment frustration anger rage it's
going to be a false set of a false piece
so be very clear on the front and this
isn't just you out so that ah it's not
how that works in 30 days we're going to
get back together and have a
conversation I strongly recommend you'll
have a a marriage counselor that y all
work through this thing together and
then I would ask her for a specific
items not of things you got to work on
because what you're going to do like any
good person recovering from addiction is
you're going to make her falling back in
love with you your new addiction and
you're going to do a bunch of things to
try to make her
happy and that's not the point what you
want to do is say what are the things I
need to do that can help you feel
safe and then I'm going to challenge you
man to go to AA for a season go to your
counseling stuff but go to a meeting
every day because I think you're going
to find out about
yourself all right you can't lose weight
for her you can't just stop drinking for
her because you're going to find
alternative things to keep that distance
from her and it's going to
in you see what I'm saying she thinks in
her mind if he'll just quit doing X then
I'll be okay and you quit doing X and
she's realizing I still don't feel that
same way and you here's the final thing
y'all can't go
back what what was is
over and y'all have to decide are we
going to build something new
right do and I've laid that out to to
her I said I'm I'm totally in with
rebuilding it with you and she's just
not in that place right now okay well um
I
think it sounds like you're going
willingly
right I mean I don't want to do anything
else that's gonna possibly expedite us
getting a divorce or anything so okay um
I'm just trying to do what I need to do
to hopefully get things going in the
right direction all right I want you to
um Google it's Terry real t e r r y r e
a l Terry real I think it's the 10 rules
of a of a
separation okay I want y'all to use that
as a guidepost and I want you to bring
your counselor in on it also and that's
going to set the stage for this 30-day
thing to we're going to take a break
from each other I'm going to start
getting myself well because I'm worth
being well she is going to let some of
the Smoke Clear from her Anger from her
rage from her not feeling safe inside
her own house and begin to write it like
here's where we're headed here's what I
here's what I need to feel safe you're
going to have some regular touch points
you're going to be upfront and adults
about with the kids and then in 30 days
youall going to circle back and that
30-day meeting might be in a counselor's
office I can't recommend this enough
that at that 30-day meeting you each
write each other a letter and read it to
each other otherwise it's it's either
going to be a blubbery mess or a you're
going to forget stuff but have a letter
at the that 30-day period that you can
hold and read and hand to that person
when you're done and um and vice versa
she's got to have one for you and maybe
it's I need another 30 days I need 15
more days or I'm not coming back I'm
going to file for divorce and I want to
do this amicably or I'm ready to build
something completely new with you but
I'm going to be super super
honest something in the way you're
talking to me says you're not done
yet and and that's if there's one place
where people will hold you accountable
it's in
AA and I would love for you to go to a
meeting and it may just be that you have
two little daughters and you have run
out of tools I don't know how to love in
my house I don't know how to be a dad to
two little girls I've got to get some
more tools and so just creating space
and distance which is what alcohol gives
you which is what dishonesty gives you
which is what Netflix gives you just
creating that space so you don't do
something wrong ends up poisoning the
whole house maybe that's what it is and
you need to learn some parenting skills
Etc but you got to repair your
relationship with your
wife or she's going to have to call it
like she is kind of circling the wagons
just and it feels like it's headed that
way um terry.com pull out that that
checklist and go down that road and then
holler back at me after 30 days me I'd
love to see where you're where you're
going what you're doing if you want to
read your letter to her um I would love
that but I don't want you creating a
30-day writing a 30-day screenplay so
you can act as though you're the person
she needs I want you to begin to get
well for you at the end of the day
that's the only person you can take care
of in
control